so if you're in the position of trying
to figure out what you want to do with
your life or the easiest ways to decide
is figure out how big the opportunity is
and cut out everything that's below what
actual goal you want to have in your
life I had a mentor tell me if the thing
isn't going to make you a billion
dollars in your career then it's not
worth putting your attention to it's not
that I can't make money doing X Y or Z
it's of all of the things I could
possibly do if all of them take time why
not go and pursue the one that has the
highest potential upside so when you
start pursuing an opportunity make sure
it's the biggest one and then that way
nothing below that line ever distracts
you from your ultimate goal for you it
might not be a billion dollars but pick
whatever number feels realistically
attainable to you and then draw a line
and say nothing below that am I going to
pursue